so this kind of self
building Loop
it's interesting to understand because
when you look at Mojo what it stands for
some of the features
it seems sort of clear that this is a
good direction for programming languages
to evolve in the machine Learning
Community but still not obvious that it
will because of this
whatever the engine of popularity of
virality is there something you could
speak to like how how do you get people
to switch Yeah well I mean I think that
the the the the viral growth Loop is to
switch people to Unicode yeah I think
the Unicode file extensions are what I'm
betting on I think that's going to be
the thing yeah tell the kids that you
could use the fire emojis exactly what
exactly
well in all seriousness like I mean I
think there's really I'll give you two
opposite answers one is
I hope if it's useful if it solves
problems and if people care about those
problems being solved
they'll adopt the tech
right that's that's kind of the simple
answer and when you're looking to get
Tech adopted the question is is it
solving an important problem people need
solved and is the adoption cost low
enough that they're willing to make the
switch and cut over and do do the pain
up front so they can actually do it
right
and so hopefully Mojo will be that for a
bunch of people and
you know people building these hybrid
packages are suffering it's really
painful and so I think that we have a
good shot of helping people but the
other side is like it's okay if people
don't use Mojo
like it's not my job to say like
everybody should do this like I'm not
saying python is bad like I hope python
see python like all these
implementations because python
ecosystems not just C python it's also a
bunch of different implementations with
different trade-offs and this ecosystem
is really powerful and exciting as are
other programming languages it's not
like typescript or something is going to
go away right and so it's not a there's
not a winner take all thing and so I
hope that Mojo is exciting and useful to
people but if it's not that's also fine
but I also wonder what the
the use case
for why you should try Mojo would be so
practically speaking Yeah
it seems like uh so there's
entertainment there's a dopamine hit of
saying holy this is 10 times faster
uh this little piece of code is
sometimes faster in Mojo out of the box
before you get to 35 000. exactly I mean
just even that I mean that's the
dopamine hit that
uh every programmer sort of dreams of is
uh the optimization it's it's also the
drug that can uh pull you in and have
you waste way too much of your life
without optimizing and over optimizing
right
um but so what uh what do you see it
would be like comedy is this very hard
to predict of course but
um you know if you look 10 years from
now on Mojo's uh super successful what
do you think would be the thing
where people like try it and then use it
regularly and it kind of grows and grows
and grows let's say you talk about
dopamine hit and so one again humans are
not one thing and
some people love rewriting their code
and learning new things and throwing
themselves in the deep end and trying
out anything
in my experience most people don't
like they're too busy they have other
things going on
um by number most people don't want like
this I want to rewrite all my code
what
even those people the two busy people
the people that uh don't actually care
about the language that just care about
getting stuff done those people do like
learning new things
right and so you talk about the dopamine
Rush of 10x faster wow that's cool I
want to do that again well it's also
like here's here's the thing I've heard
about in a different domain and I don't
have to write all my code I can learn a
new trick right well that's called
growth you know and so and so one thing
that I think is cool about Mojo and
again those will take a little bit of
time for for example the blog posts and
the books and like all that kind of
stuff develop and the language needs to
get further along but what we're doing
you talk about types like you can say
look you can start with the world you
already know and you can progressively
learn new things and adopt them where it
makes sense
if you never do that
that's cool you're not a bad person
if you if you get really excited about I
want to go all the way in the deep end
and want to rewrite everything and
they're like whatever that's cool right
but I think the middle path is actually
the more likely one where it's um you
know you you come out with a new a new
idea and you discover wow that makes my
code way simpler way more beautiful way
faster way whatever and I think that's
what people like now if you fast forward
and you said like 10 years out right
uh I can give you a very different
answer on that which is I mean
if you go back and look at what
computers look like 20 years ago
every 18 months they got faster for free
right 2x faster every 18 months it was
like clockwork it was it was free right
you go back 10 years ago and we entered
in this world where suddenly we had
multi-core CPUs and we had gpus and if
you squint and turn your head what a GPU
is it's just a many core very simple CPU
thing kind of right and so
um and 10 years ago it was CPUs and gpus
and graphics
today we have CPS gpus graphics
and AI because it's so important because
the compute is so demanding because of
the smart cameras and the watches and
all the different places the AI needs to
to work on our lives it's caused this
explosion of hardware
and so part of my thesis part of my
belief of where Computing goes if you
look out 10 years from now it's not
going to get simpler
physics isn't going back to where we
came from it's only gonna get weirder
from here on out right and so to me the
exciting part about what we're building
is it's about building that Universal
platform which the world can continue to
get weird because again I don't think
it's avoidable it's physics but we can
help lift people's scale do things with
it and they don't have to rewrite their
code every time a new device comes out
and I think that's pretty cool and so if
Mojo can help with that problem then I
think that it will be hopefully quite
interesting and quite useful to a wide
range of people because there's so much
potential and like there's some you know
maybe analog computers will become a
thing or something right and we need to
be able to get into a mode where we can
move this programming model forward but
do so in a way where we're lifting
people and and growing them instead of
forcing them to rewrite all their code
and exploding them do you think there'll
be a few major libraries that go Mojo
first
uh well so I mean the modular engines
all Mojo
so I can't come back to like we're not
building Mojo because it's fun we're
building Mojo because we had to to solve
these accelerators that's the origin
story but I mean ones that are currently
in Python yeah so I think that a number
of these projects will and so one one of
the things again this is just my best
guess like each of the package
maintainers also has I'm sure plenty of
other things going on people don't like
really don't like rewriting code just
for the sake of rewriting code
um but sometimes like people are excited
about like adopting a new idea yeah it
turns out that while rewriting code is
generally not People's First
thing turns out that redesigning
something while you rewrite it and using
a rewrite as an excuse to redesign can
lead to the 2.0 of your thing that's way
better than the 1.0 right and so I have
no idea I can't predict that but there's
a lot of these places where again if you
have a package that is half C and half
python right you just solve the pain
make it easier to move things faster
make it easier to bug and evolve your
Tech adopting Mojo kind of makes sense
to start with and then it gives you this
opportunity to rethink these things so
the two big gains are that the there's a
performance gain
and then
um there's the portability to all kinds
of different devices and their safety
right so you talk about real types
I mean not saying this is for everybody
but that's actually a pretty big thing
right yeah types are and and so there's
a bunch of different aspects of what you
know what value Mojo provides and so I
mean it's funny for me like I've been
working on these kinds of Technologies
and tools for too many years now
um but you look at Swift right and we
talked about Swift for tensorflow but
Swift as a programming language right
for uh Swift's now
13 years old from when I started it yeah
so because I started in 2010 if I
remember and so
that that project and I was involved
with it for 12 years or something right
that that project has gone through its
own really interesting story arc right
and it's a mature successful used by
millions of people system right uh
certainly not dead yet right but but
also going through that story arc I
learned a tremendous amount about
building languages about building
compilers about working with community
and things like this and so that
experience like I'm helping Channel and
bring directly into Mojo and you know
other systems same thing like apparently
I like building building and iterating
and evolving things and so you look at
this lvm thing I worked on 20 years ago
you look at mlir right and so a lot of
the Lessons Learned in lvm got fed into
mlir and I think that mlr is a way
better system than lvm was and you know
Swift is a really good system and it's
it's it's amazing but I hope that Mojo
will take the next step for
step forward in terms of uh design